hello everybody and welcome to part 15
of let's play penumbra the Black Plague
as you know we just left off after I
murdered the only woman left in this
entire place that's her I was very sad
but last I must move on I have to
complete this game okay substance 65
okay I already mixed quite a few
chemicals in the chem lab I still have
no words for what Clarence did for what
I did I helped my anger tied to my chest
and used it I used it to keep go all
right yes I'm very sad about that
I'm sure Clarence is gonna chip in and
you know screw you guys they don't you
two we're really not that bad together
so we just call it quits time if you
stop trying to destroy me huh I'll give
you a shiny penny oh that seems worth it
uh huh I'm not go for that all right I
remember I got five chemicals so there's
one chemical that I missed somewhere I
don't know where though um
Jagga nitrogen in somehow mysterious
solid form this door is still broken for
when I hacked it all uber lead um
alright okay so got the stuff from in
here
nothing just milk jugs I put them all in
let's see mix you're not complete I
looked at this guy um checking around
okay I'm gonna check every single room
cuz I'm hoping that it's from here
unless maybe I don't know I don't know I
don't know let me check
oh I know I think I know it's not in
here it's in the chemical lab this isn't
this isn't the chemical lab okay I know
I know I know
alright I'm about to prove how smart I
am yeah like the million times I've
proved it before as if you needed any
more proof to my smartness levels
alright let's see oh another guy oh not
even a little scared not even a little
bit chem lab okay chem lab chem lab here
no no no no budge chem lab oh yeah yeah
right here
Oh stupid ooh
uh-huh okay this is exciting
ah there we go okay got to put on my gas
mask all the narrow vision mobile get up
oh but Dad don't know what that's all I
could have done that a year ago
God oh man alright nevermind this can go
off yeah all right well that's
phenomenal that just proves how smart I
am I trying off f you I'm telling
laughter yeah they're everywhere oh go
on
turn around you'll get us killed shut up
I'll go further Vaughn oh you turn over
Oh nope nope not gonna happen oh if all
what's this ah ah ah forget it
all yeah Oh Boop no not gonna happen
Boop oh you you're concerned about me
shut up oh oh yeah
good chunk lip help boot get out of here
you're lucky you're with me Clarence
uh-huh uh-huh whatever whatever huh
camera oh damn it
give it Chuba moo boo-boo I see okay I
got this I got this
Oh was it oh oh yeah oh so Pro metal
gear solid action going on oh oh yeah
all yeah
Oh who's the best I'll come on all right
oh ho it's our camera or nothing
hello oh yeah Boop Jim everybody just
wait a minute maybe we got off on the
wrong foot and you don't have to go
Julie Oh fu you kill damn Abele's
I hate you I know
yeah yeah you're gonna die oh you're
gonna die hardcore like I've died ten
times before this I'll get ready also
Pro oh so bro
let's see there's a switch II switch we
got here oh oh hello hello camera Oh
nope
okay that's pretty cool I like this whoo
op yep there we go up B DVD yep I win
I'll Clarence your ghost so gonna burn
you're going to burn for this oh no I'm
a flashlight oh I use a flare cuz I got
end of them I put the switch switch is
there another switch two switches double
switch all a double switch yeah that
one's done all camera can't get me let's
see um not here I'll go away camera
that's right you knew what was good for
ah yeah double switch oh it's a double
switch aw it's so beautiful
Oh what does it mean alright but later
but no wait be careful up what's wrong
what's wrong
trunk overdue yeah buddy bit wha-what
done ah yeah yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah
not even close not even close not even
close gimme
Oh grab it grab it Oh I mean grab it
troop workers in it young workers always
wears Oh God those boys yeah all gears
and be assured you store your video sign
up I'm gonna get whatever this is our
issue uh-huh all right oh so great oh
I'm the best look at me go
I don't even need to look at my notebook
I know what's going on up Boop hey what
the hell come on get get get it and then
like Ram it through there Ram it Ram it
in and then let go oh come on
lid is closed
how do I open it computer oh yeah
Diagnostics um uh human habits do you
wish to engage the emergency school yes
awesome
yep sure is yes I am
ahahaha ah yeah what of it
so what Fu I don't I'm not apologized
for anything yes
yep there is oh yeah I am
nope not me it's very literal it is
literally an emergency oh thank you
yes what you son of a I'm gonna you
uh-oh
so that's a troll trick Oh f you f you f
you up the a oh I got a container can I
shove it in here oh yeah there we
hey hey Oh get away let me try it
give me come here I want it I need that
ah where I go oh did I get it or did I
get it Oh what happened oh no oh no I
fell through the floor uh [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass oh oh damn it oh [ __ ] me did
it go ah [ __ ] that god damn it
sorry guys sorry about that God as all
that is bad cuz oh did it do I even have
a save do i okay yeah I think I do
okay oh sorry about that guys I got
damnit wasted your time I hate to do
that I feel bad even when I'm running
around not knowing what to do it's worse
when I know what to do and I
intentionally screw it up okay alright
okay oh oh it's an emergency I'll close
it
oh no it's a monster Oh what computer
you're useless sorry I'm really sorry
about that
alright anyway moving on going this way
oh look it's a crystal oh you need to go
oh she's working all over
that way material down Oh
grabby grab get it oh yes shut up come
on come on up up nope sorry that was
wrong one
alright here we go oh it is so it but um
mother hurt big ah uh all right there we
go
a shadow shadow shadow trick me there we
go okay did I get it I get it
I got it it's in there I know it's in
there I know it is I know it Oh save ah
annoying shut up something such a baby
about it
oh they got your soul whatever whatever
okay like I'm gonna cut it real right
here real quick but I will continue
playing I'll see you guys in part 16 of
let's play penumbra the Black Plague bye
bye